there was a lot going on in our film in
terms of action really from start to
finish and you wanted it to be as
believable and as and is kind of scary
and maximize its impact including this
one fight that that I had to do
people shouldn't notice for this but
that fight which I think works really
well
that's one take
about a two minute long take you know we
put together a little fight and shot it
and you know it was about a two-minute
fight
and that turned into one take let's do
the whole fight in one take with our
lead actor smash into walls flipping
over desks you know a real gritty like
he's not a trained fighter in the film
so he's just a normal guy trying to
survive this is rare but to do a fight
with one camera and just shoot the whole
fight because normally you break a fight
down into five bits six bits seven bits
and you just do it each piece again and
again and again and cover it in
different ways that we just practice it
and practice it and practiced it because
every hit every move had to be right for
the one camera and if you made one
mistake you had to start from scratch we
didn't use a stunt person it was Jerry
doing everything now physically to do a
two minutes done scene
if you're not a been serious training
that's tough just physically going it's
tough for him and it's tough for Eric
the camera operator but myself and John
Francois felt that that scene would be
amazing if we could do it as a one take
thing
Gerard just stepped up I mean
I don't know what other actors we could
do that with but Gerard was all in
rarely do you do you make from that long
and that they work and but again that
was where Jim had to be very involved to
make sure that nobody including the crew
were getting hurt because there was a
lot of stuff flying around